par christophe prudhomme merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france c'est le fameux
syndrome post traumatique qui guette
maintenant les soignants écoutez vous
savez les soignants déjà avant la crise
n'allait pas bien puisque depuis des
années nous dénonçons le fait que de
nombreux suicides touchent le personnel
soignant à un regard des conditions de
travail d'un management qui est souvent
harceleur et nous nous avions dit au
précédent ministre déjà à marisol
touraine et agnès buzyn que la situation
dans ce domaine était pire que celle
qu'avait connue france télécom à 16
heures les plus hauts il faut savoir que
dans mon hôpital à bobigny il ya peu de
temps un professeur de médecine s'était
suicidé sur son lieu de travail en se
défenestrant de son bureau
donc là l'appel de crise a aggravé cette
situation avec les conditions de travail
très difficiles
un engagement important et une
administration qui n'a pas répondu aux
besoins des soignants puisque nous nous
avons réclamé pendant des semaines des
équipements de protection efficace et en
nombre et donc quand vous avez et
subissent ce stress et que la pression
diminue
eh bien vous avez ce qu'on appelle ce
fameux stress post traumatique qui se
manifeste et de nombreux collègues
effectivement aujourd'hui ne vont pas
bien alors comment se manifeste que ce
malaise précisément mérité c'est souvent
lié au fait que on s'épuise au travail
c'est à dire que pendant la période de
crise un certain nombre de soignants en
quasiment vécu à l'hôpital vous savoir
que certains soignants pour ne pas
contaminer leurs familles ont quitté
leur famille pour loger près de
l'hôpital ou dans l'hôpital donc ils se
sont investis à 100% dans le travail
tant qu' on a cet investissement eh bien
on pense pas à soi le travail de nous
protège
mais quand on revient à une activité
normale eh bien
l'atterrissage est très vif
si seul autant qu'aujourd'hui nous
revenons à des conditions qui sont dans
certains endroits pire qu'avant vous
savez là je j'étais de garde
hier nous avons toujours un manque de
personnel
un manque de lits un hôpital qui ne va
pas bien donc revenir à cette situation
après s'être investi après avoir été
qualifié de lourd fossé ne sort pas les
rôles nous sommes là on fait notre
travail
voilà une la fin de twilight à des
conditions qui étaient difficiles et
avec un fort ressentiment contre le
gouvernement contre l'administration qui
nous a pas donné les moyens de
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
d'autant que ces soignants ont été
applaudis tous les soirs à 20h on s'en
souvient pendant ces mois donc il
s'interdisait de crack et finalement
c'est dur aussi de revenir à la normal
quand on a vécu quand on a vécu cette
période
lui c'est très dur de revenir à une
période où alors que pour nombreux
d'entre les soignants depuis un an se
sont mobilisés autour de revendications
qui sont assez simples un des effectifs
des augmentations de salaires et l'arrêt
des fermetures de lits et qu'est ce que
le propose aujourd'hui le gouvernement
c'est ça qui rend aussi ce retour à la
normale entre guillemets difficile des
médailles et un défilé le 14 juillet
vous avez ceux qui ne craque pas ils
sont très en colère et vos expériences
galvez yann figure de la santé qui est
en étude actuellement christian et
christophe prudhomme vous en attendez
quoi et vous en espérez quoi pour
l'instant on n'en attend rien du tout
parce que le gouvernement depuis 15
jours nous balade aucune proposition bly
nous avons posé des revendications
chiffres et donc quand on pose des
revendications en face il doit y avoir
des propositions
aujourd'hui le gouvernement nous a fait
aucune proposition concrète
donc je vous dis c'est cette attente
déçue de la part des personnels aggrave
la situation
parce que vous savez les gens sont très
attachés à leur métier et il espère une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail après l'investissement qui a été
le nom
à tous or on ne voit rien venir des
médailles à défiler le 14 juillet est
une prime pour solde de tout compte
c'est parce qu'on le monde
voilà donc c'est j'oublie ceux
aujourd'hui qui ne craque pas et bien
heureusement qu'ils expriment leur
colère et je pense que lorsque leur s
exprimer de manière plus virulente
ce qui se replient sur eux-mêmes et
qu'ils n'y croient plus séché cela qu'il
faut qu'on détecte ce qu'ils vont pas
bien qui effectivement baisse les bras
entre la dépression ou dans le burn out
parce que face à la crise ou en rouleaux
compresseurs ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui reprend reprend la politique
d'avant à l'hôpital en pire
c'est à dire pour vous donner juste un
exemple nous allons fermer les chambres
à deux lits pour éviter les
contaminations
aujourd'hui on espérerait que ces
chambres rouvre eh bien nous on les
laisse en rade les donc nous avons moins
de vie qu'avant moins de personnel ce
qui aggrave les conditions de travail et
cette dureté du travail fait que
aujourd'hui les gens craquent
voilà parce que il ne croit pas aux
promesses du gouvernement et quand vous
ne croyez pas à des promesses
après quand vous êtes qualifiés de héros
quand vous est encensé en permanence et
vient pour comprendre que cette
déception puisse effectivement des
bouchers chez les plus faibles d'entre
nous est la dépression voire pillant
quand on sait que le gouvernement a
débloqué des milliards pour redresser le
pays économiquement nous penser que une
hausse des salaires immédiate aurait été
utile tout de suite de celle ci ce qui
est incompréhensible pour les soignants
c'est que nous sommes investies et on
annonce pour des entreprises et c'est
peut-être légitime encore que bon 5
milliards pour renault 7 milliards pour
la france klm air france ces quarante
mille emplois en france
c'est une activité économique importante
mais l'hôpital c'est plus d'un million
de salariés
combien de milliards vous savez
aujourd'hui on a jeté un chiffrage à la
louche pour rattraper le retard sur les
salaires
pour mettre les finances de l'hôpital à
plat sans préjuger de ce qu'il faut là
l'an prochain
aujourd'hui de vison monsieur macro nous
voulons au minimum au minimum 10
milliards tout de suite 10 milliards au
dessus sur la table ont trop beau je
peux vous dire que je lance la tête ce
soir le 14 juillet nous sommes très
nombreux à vouloir aller à la sauterie
du président est peut-être qu'on
organise à une très bonne prestation sur
les champs elysées pour protester
d'autant que les scientifiques disent
que peut-être une deuxième vague est à
prévoir à la rentrée à l'automne
vous seriez prêt à affronter de nouveau
une crise d'ampleur doit absolument pas
ils vous savez je conteste les propos du
premier ministre du président de la
république
l'hôpital n'a pas tenu si l'hôpital avec
lui nous aurions moins deux morts ils
nous en ont pas eu cette crise
gravissime avec dans les régions comme
l'ile-de-france où la région grand est
ces difficultés pour trouver des places
de réanimation vous savez il ya un
certain nombre de pays qui avaient
beaucoup plus de place de réanimation
que nous et un hôpital en bien meilleure
santé
eh bien il n'y a pas eu cette crise pour
la connu en france et heureusement que
l'épidémie n'a touché que quelques
régions parce que si elle s'était temps
étendue avec la même intensité à
l'ensemble du territoire
la soirée était vraiment catastrophique
parlons des syndromes post traumatiques
monsieur prudhomme le fait d'avoir
côtoyé aussi la mort alors on la
côtoient évidemment tant que soignant
régulièrement mais à 7
à ce rythme infernal en tout cas et sans
les familles pour venir soutenir ses
personnels est évidemment les victimes
ça aussi c'est traumatisant bien sûr
comme je le disais s'investit y compris
ne pas avoir de contact avec sa famille
puisque un certain nombre de collègues
préféré ne pas avoir de contact avec
leurs familles et se sont isolés
c'est une situation très difficile et
quand ça dure pendant plusieurs semaines
eh bien il faut comprendre que c'est
effectivement un traumatisme important
et un quant à la sortie de cette crise
eh bien oui on nous propose des
entretiens avec des psychologues mais
vous savez la meilleure thérapie c'est
de revenir
au travail dans des conditions qui sont
améliorées la meilleure thérapie c'est
le soutien des collègues des personnels
et la renaissance
ce n'est pas le cas la reconnaissance
elle n'est qu'en paroles on veut une
reconnaissance concrète pas que les
promesses regardez toutes les
manifestations les mardis la colère les
jeudis de la colère et nous aurons une
grande manifestation le 16 juin
nous sommes insatisfaits concrètement
vous dire le gouvernement se fout de
nous et ça ça ce mépris ce mépris
concrets qui contredit les promesses les
paroles lénifiantes du chef de l'état et
chef de l'état ça c'est catastrophique
pour les soignants catastrophique
vous comprenez on veut pas de promesses
on veut pas le qualifier de l'hérault on
ne veut pas de médaille
on veut qu'on réponde à nos demandes
pour améliorer les conditions de travail
la meilleure thérapie pour les soignants
qui ne vont pas bien aujourd'hui c'est
que on ne met plus de collègues que les
conditions de travail s'améliorent qu'on
ait un management qui soit beaucoup
moins harceleur alors qu'aujourd'hui
j'avais dans mon hôpital dans mon
hôpital à bobigny
nous manifestons les jeudis et quelle
est la réponse du gouvernent de de la
direction de l'hôpital
c'est de nous envoyer un huissier pour
contrôler les non dits des agents qui
aujourd'hui manifestent à robert debré
et dont vous diffuser les images
j étais jeudi à 8 15 cars de crs 15 cars
de crs est ce que nous sommes des gens
dangereux quand simplement du manifesto
pour défendre notre outil de travail
pour traiter mais on en passe
merci christophe prudhomme